House and Senate Republicans are racing
to combine their separate tax reform
bills GOP lawmakers will work this week
to try and sort out the differences in
the two plans Republicans want a
finished bill on president Trump's desk
by Christmas Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with the hurdles they face and
whether they'll be able to wrap a bow
around it Nancy good morning good
morning House and Senate Republicans
have been working behind the scenes to
reconcile these two bills even before
the Senate passed its bill early
Saturday morning and they believe Norah
that they can get that process done
within a week the middle income tax
payers overwhelming majority I'll go get
tax relief Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell insisted Sunday that melding
the two tax bills will not take much
time we'll be able to get to an
agreement in the conference I'm very
optimistic about it he'll be working
with House GOP leaders like Steve
Scalise highly motivated to pass a final
bill by Christmas when you look at the
differences they're not that big but
there are some key discrepancies the
Senate bill keeps the current seven
individual tax brackets while the House
bill condenses it to four the Senate
bill eliminates Obamacare's individual
mandate a move that's likely to end up
in the final product and it's unclear
what would happen to medical expense
deductions the House bill eliminates
them but the Senate bill expands them
temporarily senator Susan Collins of
Maine was responsible for that
last-minute addition the amendments that
I added on medical expense deductions
some property tax deductions on helping
retirement security for public employees
and proof that bill changes like those
were made in pen just hours before the
Senate vote early Saturday morning
this is attachment Democrats took to
social media to rail against the rushed
process can you tell me what that word
is if you can you got better eyes than
me c-corporation Prynne dangerous that
can't be right
some of those last-minute revisions
surprised even House Republicans like
the decision not to repeal the
alternative minimum tax and trying to
melt these two bills now is going to be
a very delicate process because they
can't do anything that's going to
jeopardize GOP votes in the house and
particularly in the Senate Gale where
they have just one vote to spare all
right that's not a lot thank you very
much Nancy